you
I'm going to tell you about four
delightful decades I've had examining
the structure of the synapse actually
I'm standing in front of a giant picture
of us in apps that I took about 40 years
ago the inside the synapse you can see
these little circles those are synaptic
vesicles and then you see those dense
areas at the bottom that's a place where
the one nerve cell the presynaptic nerve
cell contacts the other nurse el the
postsynaptic neuron cells right there
that the presynaptic nerve cell releases
transmitter to send a signal to the
postsynaptic nurse'll now once we had
these pictures and the the group at
University College London had shown that
this release of transmitter comes a
little squirts they called them quanta
it seemed obvious from the pictures that
their vesicles might contain the quanta
so that was known as the vesicle
hypothesis and this is where I came into
the picture we had no idea how vesicles
might release the transmitter or how new
vessels might be reformed after they
released their transmitter at that point
John heuser joined my lab from
University College London where they
were working on the this beautiful
preparation the frog neuromuscular
junction which is a sausage-shaped
structure I've got my hand out right
here and you can see it has synaptic
vesicles it's like it sets of SAP's
between a nerve and a muscle rather than
between a nerve and a nerve and the
structure is beautifully clear and so we
decided that we would simulate it and
see what happens to what changes in
structure might occur of on simulation
that would tell us something about was
how the quanta are release or at least
remade so when we stimulated we've got
an amazing result the many of the
synaptic vesicles disappeared and in
their place these big vacuole things
appeared and the vacuoles are filled
inside the SAPS and also inside the
Senate
there are little tiny vessels with fuzzy
stuff on them these are coated vesicles
and they were known to be the way it
sells recover things from the outside
this made us think maybe the vesicles
are being released somehow or used up
somehow and then they're being recovered
by bringing in more surface membrane if
that's a case we should be able to test
it by using a dense material you can see
the electron microscope now the
synapsids been stimulated here recovers
it within minutes and so if we put the
dense material around the outside let it
recover if it's if the outside is the
source of new synaptic vesicles in the
staff event vesicles should have a dense
material in it and indeed they did so
here are synaptic vesicles with dense
material this was the synapse with
simulated it's recovered and taken up
the dense material into synaptic
vesicles this led us to propose a theory
of synaptic vesicle recycling the idea
is that the synaptic vesicles are
released and become part of the surface
and we thought this might be the case
because when you stimulate synapse it
gets bigger but after the vesicles on
the surface it's recovered by these
little code vesicles pinching off and
also perhaps by large vesicles pinching
off directly when you have very high
levels of release and once inside the
membranes get sorted out back and made
back into synaptic vesicles so that's
the theory of synaptic vesicle recycling
the paper was very well received John
went back to London and we were left
scratching our heads because this theory
was very unsatisfying and incomplete
from both our points of view the problem
being that we could see vesicles lined
up on the surface where we couldn't see
how they released the reason we couldn't
see is because we're using chemical
fixative they're very very slow and so
by time to fix they've got there
everything was over and we couldn't
really catch that fleeting event that
would involve the release of a skort of
transmitter we thought maybe maybe we
could do this with freezing and there
was an old freezing machine in my lab
they never worked and so while John was
in London I got it down and started
working with it and I introduced a new
technique I
come back to in a minute later i'm not
going to say a lot about it's called
freeze fracture and allows you to see
the service of synapse rather than
looking inside the synapse and looking
at the services of synapse aight see
this freezing machine was sort of
working we could occasionally see what
looked like vesicles coming out so I
call up John and London I say John get
over here and let's get to work on this
and he came over for about two months
and we worked with this machine with
very very spotty results and we were
scratching our heads we didn't know what
was wrong but John gets a call from
University College and from New York
City California San Francisco would you
like to have a position out here so John
goes out to San Francisco and that
begins five years of he and I going back
and forth across the country to try to
work out this problem now this is John
and who came back from London and we
spent a lot of time together very
intense time the University College San
Francisco time was so intense that
people it sort of cleared the oxygen out
his lab a lot of people left we argued
like old married couples every day and
people said it was just terrible and in
fact some people thought we might be an
old married couple but we weren't but we
were just intensely linked and this is
his quest to try to figure this thing
out and we kept doing freezing runs and
freezing runs and getting air once a
while we get a little result and it
suddenly occurred to bow to us and when
you earn in this close relationship you
never know whose idea is the ideas has
come together and that if you drop
something on something that it's going
to bounce and so these machines that
were trying to drop things on the cold
metal plates we're going to bounce and
so we build a machine that was designed
not to bounce using a neighborhood
remarkable machinist at university of
california called jim wall who made the
electrode pulling machines and so this
is an adaptation of electrode poor it's
essentially an arm that holds the tissue
drops it down onto a block cooled with
liquid helium now the key
here was that we used a big heavy metal
ring in a big strong magnet and we also
use spring loading and by adjusting the
springs and the magnets and we used
electrical contact her to see what was
actually happening land yet we figured
out that we certain combinations of
forces we could get rid of the bounce
was very hard but once we got rid of the
bounce we started getting beautiful
freezing every time and we could then go
and look at the at the neuromuscular
junctions now this machine that Jim
build us had a frog neuromuscular
Junction was not on that little little
plunger thing on the end and on that
plunger was a little wire hook to wire
hooks and we could hook the nerve to the
muscle so on the way down there's a
trigger and we could trigger a stimulus
and stimulate the nerve right before the
muscle got frozen and we could look at
explore different time periods and we
did some electrical measurements of its
freezing rain we found that with
freezing less than 10 to the millisecond
so we were able to do structure for the
first time in sub millisecond resolution
now when we look at the neuromuscular
junction it rests with no stimulation we
saw what we expected vesicles full of
[ __ ] some lined up on the surface
but when we stimulated four milliseconds
before it hit at two milliseconds we saw
nothing four milliseconds all of a
sudden the whole surface of the nerve
Egan's to bubble and you see little
things that look like vesicles opening
they were down there and over there
there little flasks and the vesicle is
fused and open now I want to stress this
happens within milliseconds and if you
wait a few more milliseconds these
vesicles proceed to flatten out and
dissolve into the surface now using the
streets fracture technique which shows
us the surface we could actually see
that remember now the vesicles a little
flasks and if you look at from the
surface it would look like a ring and as
it flattened out the ring would expand
so what you see are different times or
is it remember
left to right as a ring expanding and
finally it flattens out completely
flattens out and you just see a little
indentation so this is a sequence of
events it shows that the vesicles are
actually fusing and becoming part of the
of the surface now this is exactly what
we wanted to see to fill in the gap in
our recycling theory because the
recycling Theory said that the new
vegetables were coming from the surface
so how the vesicles go to the service
well now we could sexually see vesicles
join the surface and flattening out on
the service furthermore we could count
the number of these events and we could
measure physiologically how many sports
there were and we could relate a number
of squirts to the number of structural
events and at different levels of
release and they match perfectly so it
seemed it we had very direct evidence of
the of the vesicle recycling hypothesis
now any any theory you come up with is
going to have its detractors and people
are going to start start start in on you
which is good because that's what
science is supposed to be about and so
people started to think well maybe some
vesicles recycle maybe other vesicles
just come up to the surface and make a
little opening and release a little
square of transmitter and that was
called kiss and run theory and John
remarked why would anybody kiss and run
when you could stay but there are more
and more evidence coming up up for kiss
and run and it seems to me that it has a
small part in some synapses for some
reasons we don't really know why yet and
the vesting is structurally such a small
rapid event would be difficult even of
these freezing techniques so that was a
delightful decade of examining synaptic
structure and one night late one night
John are sitting are exhausted and I
turned to John so why the hell are we
doing this our lives are falling apart
outside the law
our wives hate us and the why are we
doing this and john turned to me and he
said well you know tom the most
important thing in science is to be
together with a colleague at that moment
when you discover something when i when
some little piece of nature unfolds and
and you see something new
you